um so thank you very much
uh
so
i'm not sure exactly what you've already
learned in this course
uh but today i'll be just be talking
about equivariance
in machine learning
okay so before i come to that i just
wanted to briefly um advertise our
research institute
in sydney
uh so this is a research institute that
supports visits to australia
um
in mathematics so if you're interested
in visiting
australia and working with someone in
australia then um
you're welcome to apply
through our program
and we'd love to host you
so a second point is that
i love comments questions interruptions
etc so if you have a question or um
or a comment
please just
ask it
okay
so um i'm assuming that the background
of most of you is
more in computer science and less in
mathematics
so
i'm going to go over some of the
mathematical foundations of what i'm
talking about
so
i want to start off with
symmetry in mathematics
so symmetry is
almost as old as the hills
so
here's a um
theorem from
euclid's elements that was um you know
written about
um more than about 2400 years ago
or 2500 years ago
so it is the theorem that i'm sure
you're familiar with that if you take a
circle
and
you uh
consider a diameter
and then you consider any other point on
the circumference of the circle then
this is a right angle
yeah
and if you look at the proof of this
theorem
so this is a very you know very
fundamental and beautiful theorem
that we've known for two and a half
thousand years
but i just want to emphasize the fact
that kind of symmetry is
already present in this very basic
theorem
so
if you look at a proof of this theorem
you
like you know for example in
in euclid
um
you you construct a line here and then
you argue about the angle sum of a
triangle and things like this
um
but you can ask yourself like
what happens if the point is down here
what happens if my point c is down here
and then there's a very obvious thing to
do which you can just flip this diagram
upside down on this axis of symmetry and
this would place this would get the
theorem for the point down there
okay
and so there's a kind of tacit symmetry
present in mathematics for a very long
time
and group theory
so this is group theory
is the mathematical theory of symmetry
so a group
um you know i hope that you've seen this
concept before
but i'm just um reviewing it quickly so
a group is a set with a binary operation
so we have a binary operation where we
take two elements g
and g prime
in g and then
we have some operation which produces a
new element
out of our two elements so this is our
binary operation our multiplication
and this satisfies three axioms
so there's the existence of an element
which when you left or right multiplied
by that element does nothing
our operation is associative
and there exists inverses
so this is a formal definition but what
you should think about
is basically that the symmetries of any
mathematical object form a group
so for example if you have a square
and you look at the symmetries of this
square there's various things you can do
you could reflect it along this axis you
could rotate it um
and um and these axioms will be
satisfied
so i just want to emphasize so
what galwa pointed out in about 1830
so
nearly 200 years ago
is that if you consider the set of all
symmetries of a situation
these uh former group
and the structure of this group of
symmetries matters
okay
so
it's a kind of meta approach to a
problem
you might
you start with a problem
you notice that it has a whole lot of
symmetries
and in the example of euclid we use
these these symmetries kind of one by
one to simplify our
problem
but it was galwa that first said
that the set of all these symmetries
together and the structure of that set
of all symmetries is fundamental to
mathematics
okay
and klein um
explained i
uh that
geometries for example projective
geometry euclidean geometry et cetera
are determined by their groups of
symmetries
and lee developed the theory of
continuous groups so lead groups and
it's interesting that um klein and lee
were actually very good friends and they
were very inspired by gawa theory
and they apparently would meet every day
and discuss mathematics
and it was only um after they um they
separated so lee went back to norway and
klein went to heirloom that they
developed two beautiful theories of
mathematics that were somehow related
and then frobenius in 1899
so this was the beginning of
representation theory
um and then many others sure burnside
nurture vile
many others
develop representation theory which is
how might g act linearly on a vector
space
okay
so we want g to act via linear
transformations on a vector space so
this is the same thing
as asking how might g
what are the maps from g to g l
and r so this is the
group
of n by n
convertible
matrices with
real coefficients
okay so this is a very concrete problem
so i have a group so this collec this
consists of a collection of elements g
and a multiplication rule and then what
i'm doing in representation theory is
studying matrices which satisfy the same
multiplication rules as the elements of
g
okay so invertible matrices which
satisfy the same multiplication l rules
is the elements
of g
so i'll just give you two examples of
representations
so here we take
uh in my opinion one of the most
beautiful objects in mathematics namely
the icosahedron the regular icosahedron
and now if you consider a symmetry of
this icosahedron
you can represent it as a matrix
so if you imagine the you know for
example this icosahedron may have
certain rotational symmetries these
symmetries are given by a matrix
and hence we get a representation so
this group of isometries of the
icosahedron is naturally
represented by matrices
another example is if i take um
the vertices of the triangle like this
so here's e1 here's e2 his minus c1
minus c2 you can write down so there's
six symmetries of the triangle
so any permutation of the vertices is
possible and so we get
six matrices so this is for example the
identity
so this is what i was calling one before
and then for example you have the
the symmetry that interchanges these two
elements and fixes this element and
that's given by this matrix
and similarly the element that fixes
this one and interchanges this this one
is given by this matrix etcetera
okay so these are examples in
representative representations
and i just want to emphasize the
following extremely important point
so
probably so i tried to motivate group
theory via symmetry
and so
it's very
natural
to
i think group theory is very natural
we have symmetrical situations so we
should understand the symmetries
preserving
but what is not so obvious is studying
representations you know i said let's
look at all homomorphisms to matrices
and you're totally justified in thinking
why on earth does this person want to
study they study homomorphisms to
matrices
but
the 20th century has shown us that such
study study is useful
okay so
just two examples so the standard model
in fundamental physics and the language
program in mathematics
have representation theory at their core
so i this is an incredibly inspiring
paper about
um
the kind of
remarkable
appearance of symmetry in for example
the standard model
and here's in number theory um
you have a
article about the role of representation
theory and number theory
so
what we're so this is meant to be about
machine learning so why the hell am i
talking about groups and symmetry
so i just want to give you two examples
where we might want an invariant
projection
so this is a totally
beautiful picture in my opinion so this
is a flock of birds
okay
and you'll notice
that
these birds as they fly they form some
very interesting structure so they form
a kind of a circle here
and you you might you might pose
yourself the task of using machine
learning to understand this structure
so there's a comment in the chat
can you still hear me
okay
um
i'm jody
yes
so just create
the excel sheet for question
haha
yes i put the link in the
zoom chat
perfect
okay
so does anybody have any questions at
the moment
guys so if you have questions so i'll
send you a link
just put your question there
yeah
yes so that will be adding the question
in this file
sure
okay
so we can continue
uh
okay so
now imagine that you want to for example
examine the structure of this
this flock of birds
what
you might
the way that you might encode this flock
of birds into a computer is there's a
whole lot of numbered
a whole a list of vectors
okay this vector is affecting this
vector etc
um but notice that when we look at this
we don't care which bird is number one
and bird is number two we just
care about the birds without their
ordering
so this is an example where we would
like to make an invariant prediction
so
sorry invariant prediction
another example
is here i've tried i tried to find an
image on the internet of a heat
distribution on a sphere
okay so this is meant to be a sphere
and on this sphere you have areas that
are very hot
and you have areas that are cold
and you can imagine
that you want to for example train a
neural net to predict the evolution
of this um of this heat
distribution
now
the evolution of the heat distribution
would presumably be invaria the
equations determining the evolution of
the heat distribution would presumably
be invariant
under um rotations of our sphere
okay so
um
you know if if for example this
this area here moves across to here as
the system evolved and then we move the
sphere we
expect to be able to predict
where the moved distribution how the
move distribution will evolve
okay
so this is an example of evolution of um
this is an example of a prediction that
we expect to be invariant
okay
so how does one build invariant or
equivalent um
neural nets
so maybe i just noticed there was a
question in the
um
so the question is um
in some
ins in some group action some literature
include closure as the force that
actions
um yeah so that's a good question so if
we go back to the definition of a group
so here i say um
here we have a definition of a group
and then i'm implicitly so there's some
people would include a fourth one namely
closure
which is that g
and g prime in g
implies gg prime
in g
but this is implicit when i write the
multiplication in this way
so i'm kind of
secretly including this this axiom um by
writing the definition definition
definition in this way okay
so thanks for the question
okay so how do we build invariant or
equivalent neural nets that's the
question that we want to um
ask
now
and i should say that there's quite a
lot of literature on this so
um there's this paper for example on
steerable cnns group equivalent
convolutional networks this book
or the draft of the book which i think
you've been following in this course
which is geometric deep learning grids
groups graphs geodesics and gauges okay
so all
all i'm doing today is i'm basically
giving a survey of this this work
um
many references are missing and i'm not
claiming that um
that any of what i'm saying is original
okay i'm just trying to explain uh
what's going on in what i think is a
very beautiful
set of ideas
so what i find remarkable about
geometric deep learning is that it kind
of
it gives you a various a very structured
way to build a neural net
which um makes a whole lot of choices
that might appear very tricky when
you're actually making your neural net
it makes them kind of automatic
okay
so
i hope you've seen uh convolutional
neural nets
so
this is i so i'm assuming
um that you've seen convolution on your
nets
and so and what i want to view um
a
i want to consider a periodic image okay
so this is so z mod h z squared is a
grid
oops
so here i have a grid
so this would be
h
so it's an h by h grid
and
um so that's what zmod h said looks
like what i'm looking at is a function
from z mod h said squared so from this
grid to the real numbers
so that means what i associate i
associate every point here a real number
which i can interpret as being a
grayscale value
so here's an example of what a periodic
image would might look like
and
i call this a periodic image rather than
an image because kind of
like it kind of wraps around
it's more like an image on a torus
and what we seek
is
some function
that takes in a periodic image and spits
out
a real valued a real number which is for
example
it's positive on tigers and negative on
non-tigers for example and also we we
expect that it's kind of very positive
if we're sure that the image is a tiger
and neg very negative if we're sure it's
not and zero if we're not so sure
so this is what we're seeking to do so
this is a
classification task which i hope you've
seen
in other lectures
and here is a schematic of what happens
in a cnn
so we have
this is our this is our input
and then we apply various filters
so here are here our filters
and this will be our first hidden layer
and then we apply again another set of
filters and this would be our second
hidden layer
and then we might do some kind of
pooling operation
where we for example
um
we might do max pooling for example
which would take
these and then replace it by the maximum
entry in each one
and then
basically in what follows i'm kind of
going to ignore this bit
and then finally we do some fully
connected layer down to r
okay
so this should be um i hope that this is
a reasonably familiar picture
for you from um from cnn's
so convolutional neural nets
now i just want to look at this
situation through the lens of group
theory
so this is what i've just explained this
is the structure of a convolutional
neural net
and i just want to point out so this is
a group
and
um this group acts on the set of
functions via translation
so
if you if you take um
f which you regard as an as a periodic
image
and then you take an element g it just
kind of shifts your image you know up
and to the right or something like that
and the really important thing to notice
is that convolution is gamma equivalent
so what that means
is that if you
translate and then apply a filter that's
that's the same thing as applying the
filter and then translating
and there's a nice um
little exercise in
in representation theory
which is that if you look at the
that um
equivalent functions between
like
the spaces of functions
so
you know i hope it i hope it's clear but
fun
said what h said
squared is the same thing as
real valued
functions on z
what h squared
so basically um convolution is the only
equivalent thing that i can do between
these function spaces
so applying a filter is the only
equivalent thing that i can do
okay
so the first observation is that we
often want a gamma invariant answer so
like imagine that our question is
recognize a tiger
and we have a tiger in the bottom left
if we move the tiger up to the top right
it's still a tiger
so that's the statement that
we we seek a gamma invariant prediction
the other important point
is that convolution so this is
also known as applying a filter
and also
relu
so
the rectified linear unit are gamma
equivalent
and another thing that we often require
is that these filters initially
are local so that means that for example
as we're going across our image we're
only um
we're only applying a filter to a small
region of our image
and locality is the same thing as that
the filters are supported near the
identity in our group
so they're they don't change our picture
very much
now what i find remarkable
is that these three properties
namely gamma invariance gamma
equivalence and locality
basically force the answer to look like
this so if you
i don't know the first first time i saw
a convolutional neural net i thought
it's a bit of a strange definition
but if you just make these simple
assumptions that it's gamma invariant
that the lat so we want the prediction
to be gamma in
invariant
we want each of the layers to be gamma
equivalent
and
we want locality
then basically convolutional neural nets
have to be the way they are
so just see if there was any questions
so someone asked what may be the
motivation for studying the shape
of birds in the figure you had
so i'll go back to that
yeah so that's a good question so why
might we be interested in um
in studying the structure of the birds
um
yeah i i i guess my my honest answer
would be it's probably very interesting
um
and
it's yeah i'm not sure and another
another example might be that you might
have some population for example
and
you might consider their age and their
income
so you might have a whole
a whole poppy you might have um
age and income
and
perhaps you might expect so let's say
that this is age 20
and this is age 50
and maybe you expect that
income increases and then perhaps
decreases
so this might be a rough plot
but then you might
there might actually be some like
interesting hole here so
people
um
you know it might be the case that
people of age 40 either earn
a large amount or a small amount but no
one kind of burns in the middle
so that that might be something
interesting to observe in your data
um and that that would be an example of
some kind of prediction that we might be
interested in making and just as in here
in the in this bird flock we have this
kind of hole here
which might be interesting for various
reasons
okay
but i guess the important point up here
is that as in the birds we don't
actually care like
we're look we're trying to look at this
data without remembering which point
corresponds to which person
we're trying to look at global features
rather than um
[Music]
rather than specific things associated
to a specific person
now this is an extremely important um
kind of technical point
so i'll come back to the questions in a
second
so let's say
i assume you've learned what a fully
connected neural net is
so here's a fully connected neural net
uh which
so imagine that the the this has input
layer dimension l1 and
and this layer dimension is l2
now we have l1 times l2 parameters
okay
so this
even in simple examples this could be
enormous
for example if this is 10 to the 6
you know like in a typical in a typical
image
you might have 10 million pixels
so this could
realistically be
something like you know 10 to the 7
and then if you put 10 to the 7 here
that means you have
10 to the 14 parameters
which is an enormous number for um
you know
even even a good computer
whereas imagine the first layer of a
one-dimensional convolutional neural net
okay so here i have
um
so here i'm kind of imagining like a
one-dimensional image
if i impose
equivalence and locality
then regardless of the dimension i just
have three parameters here
okay so we have three parameters totally
independent of the size
which is really remarkable so you know
10 to the 14 versus three it's a big
advantage okay so um i'll just address
the questions now
um so please what is gamma
ah so sorry yeah so gamma
so gamma is
z mod h z squared
the image should always be periodic
so this was another question
uh
so
basically the the period the assumption
that the um
image is periodic is this is a
simplification
okay so this assumption um allows one to
see clearly what
what is going on and then once once
you've um
once you've seen clearly what's going on
then it can be dropped
so this is not um you know
in in in normal neural net architectures
recognizing images you don't assume that
the image is periodic
uh
but it really simplifies things to do so
and
could you explain that graph above
related to convolution and gamma
invariant
i'm not sure i understand the question
so
um
if you could clarify the question i can
try to answer it
okay
so that's really
really important this
massive drop down in parameters
when you when you
look at a cnn
so now um
we look at the
general case
so someone also asked where am i now so
i am um
i am currently in sydney in well near
sydney i am two hours from sydney in
australia
this is an this is a question that's
easy to answer
um
and
please explain the formula for the
periodic image you draw an h by h matrix
but the formula has z mod h said squared
yes so
here
oh sorry
i'm sorry this was a typo i meant to
write zmod h said squared
okay so
yeah so z mod h squared is the numbers
zero up to um
[Music]
up to h minus one so this is what i've
listed along here zero up to h minus one
and then when i take the square i get
an array
and then i'm viewing a periodic image as
being a real valued function on this
array
okay
so
what makes the dimensions remain
constant in the place of locality and
equivariance
so
maybe i can try to explain that in the
following way
so imagine
so i'm just going to move up a little
bit and i'm going to take this
so imagine here fully connected
so here we have 36 dimensions
and here we have 36 dimensions
and so here we would have
um
r to the 36 times 36 so we'd have 36
times 36 parameters
which is enormous
i mean not that enormous but
um
but still rather large
but if you think about what happens in a
convolutional neural net
then the value of this pixel
is determined
by the values of these pixels
so
and moreover this value here depends on
these in exactly the same way
as for example
this pixel determines
and so here you would only have
something like nine parameters
so
here you see that the number of
parameters changes as my images get
image gets larger
you know if i increase my image to
like
to seven or something then this would be
out of a 49 out of a 49 and then i'd
have 49 times 49 parameters here
but here it doesn't change i always just
have nine parameters
okay
so thank you for the question uh
i hope i hope i answered all the
all the questions in the um question
cheap but if i didn't just just ask more
questions
uh
okay so now i just wanted to present um
the general blueprint
so this might seem very dry
uh but it's incredibly powerful and i
hope to give it an example of why it's
powerful at the very end
i also think that in some sense it's
like it's it its power has not yet been
really appreciated and so i think that
there's many interesting examples still
to be done
so
if we consider a transitive gamma set
so this means so gamma is now any kind
of group
and what we want to do so you should
think about the the
the example
is when gamma is z mod h z squared
and you should think about this
example as being the kind of
extremely simple
um
example and i'm i'm discussing
um potentially much more complicated
situations but keep this example in mind
so what we want to do is learn some
invariant or equivalent function
from functions on x to r
now one of the things that's
um
very nice
is that
if
our action is transitive
then the only linear
uh
the only linear gamma invariant function
is just given by the
integral of our function or the sum
of our function so this is the same
thing as the
sum sum of the values of f
x and x
if x is finer
okay so mathematicians often just write
integral and when the set is finite they
mean sum
and when the set is infinite they mean
the integral in the sentence of
calculus or differential geometry
so the point of this exercise is that
there's not very many interesting
gamma invariant functions
if they're linear so we're definitely
learning a non-linear function
and basically what we do is we write
down exactly the same structure as
before
so uh
we consider functions on x and then we
consider functions on um transitive sets
transitive gamma sets
link them all up in this way
and now the important
thing to
the the important question to ask is
what are the filters
or what are the possible
convolutions
and
there's a very important formula in
representation theory called the double
concept formula which gives you an
answer in terms of group theory for what
these convolutions are
okay
so maybe um i'll just see if there's
more questions and then i might
so how is it connected to lower graph
i'm not sure i don't understand the
question how is it connected to lower
graph
okay so i might just skip over the next
bit um
and i just want to give an example of
uh
hello
yes yes i was talking
in a few minutes you explained something
that was really true they mentioned how
the parameter might change but
below for that questions there was some
graphic ready to convolutionally explain
it so we want that you can explain that
graphic clearly because we it's hard to
render things once we don't have many
explanations on that graph
so which one can you tell me which one
you mean
so there is a slide where we're
explaining the how the parameter change
when you try to go from one area to yes
yes this one
above
yes here
okay
um
and so what is
what is not what would you like me to
explain here
this graph which is below
okay this shame of cnn
okay
so um
so generally
so
imagine that we have um
a
so typically
what will happen in a cnn
is that this
so
so this is the this is this is part of
input image
okay so i imagine that this is like a
small part of a big image
and then i have a filter so i have
something like um
if
so this is my
filter
and now the formula for what happens in
a cnn is that
a value here
so
and i get a complicated
and this value here
will be equal to
this summer
okay
so maybe i can try to find
[Music]
a talk where this is shown so
i just see if i can
yes so here's an example of the filter
okay so
here's my um
here's my filter so it's minus one minus
one minus one minus my minus one minus
one minus one and it has an eight in the
middle
and now i take this image
and for every um
for every
nine by nine
pixels inside here every tiny little box
of nine by nine pixels
i
i apply the formula that i just wrote so
this means i take the nine by nine grid
and then i take the dot product with
these numbers
and then
i get this picture
and notice how
this picks out these kind of outlines
whereas
[Music]
areas where there's not much change in
color when there's a stark change in
color for example here this really shows
up after applying this filter
whereas here where there's not much
change in color i just get darkness
yeah
so this is an example of applying a
filter
did that make sense
so
the the really the the point that i'm
trying to get across here
is that
like in this neural net down here you
would have several of these layers but
each one of these
these arrows
would just requires nine parameters or
something so it just requires these nine
parameters so we do the same thing
across the whole image
so
these
um
these numbers determine
this map
across the whole image
so there's nine parameters that
determine this
this map
okay
so i'll see if there's any more
questions
okay
so yeah the the the basic point i'm
trying to make is you get this
much less parameters so it's much easier
to train
and the other point is that some kind of
group theoretic um
notions
exactly tell you kind of what to do here
so the group theory is a very powerful
tool to learn what's going on here
okay so i'll just go to the example of
deep sets and then we'll finish
okay so
in this particular case we have a point
cloud
so this is like like the birds earlier
and we would like to make some kind of
prediction based on this point cloud
okay
and there's many many situations in
machine learning where such a prediction
is necessary so you have
a large number of points but the
ordering does not matter that's the key
point
the order
so for example in the swarm of birds you
do not care which bird is which
so
many problems can be seen as learning
um
so we
we have our collection of points
so this is n points in r to the d
so this would be for example um
10 000 points in r3 so here we'd have r3
to the 10 000
and now we can
we can view this instead as
d points in r to the n
where we like first look at the first
coordinate then the second coordinate et
cetera
now
notice that rn so this is rn
is a representation
of sn the symmetric group
and what we're saying is that we don't
care we want this to be an
sn invariant prediction so what that
means is that if we reshuffle our points
and relabel them we don't want the
measurement to change
so now i employ the following notation
so big n
just means functions on this big set
and one means the trivial representation
and now you can work out it's not
difficult
to work out the sn invariant maps
between these representations
so
so basically this is determining the
kind of number of parameters
in your neural net so from the layer
from a one dimensional vector space to
one dimensional vector space there's
only one we're used to that but if you
look at an sn invariant map from n to
the identity there's in fact just one
and that's this averaging operator
and similarly you can work out this
and this is the deep set architecture so
this is of
um here at al
so here would be my input so this would
be an example of a three-dimensional
point cloud input so i'd have n points
this would be n points
in r3
and then i
choose a few a few a few units
and then
i know exactly what i can put on these
edges thanks to the formulas that i gave
on the previous slide
okay and again we get this massive
reduction
in the number of parameters
um
okay so here are some questions
if you're an expert about these
these things
and
thank you
just
[Applause]
is
i i think uh there is one question on
the fight
about lidar
i think there is one question remaining
that you didn't answer
yeah so i think the question is uh oh so
the is the point cloud similar to lidar
i don't really know what lidar is
so
um i'm not sure
probably some of you know much better
than that so please explain second last
slide
um
is this
is this what you mean by second last
slide
oh whoops i should share
is that the second last slide or is this
the second last slide
so
could you go down to the next slide
this one
come here
hi
it's laid before this one
this one
okay so
what where so this is
this is determining
parameters in our neural network
so this is saying
that
so
like let's take this example
so what we're asking is how many
so if we just view this as a vector
space so this is
as a vector space this is just r to the
n
so if we look at vector space
homomorphisms from r to the n r to the n
the dimension
is r to the n squared
okay so this is an enormously large
space
but now if we look at those
maps
from here to here
which are
equivariant for
sn
then it turns out
that there's not very many of them
so
one example is i could take the identity
another example is i could take all of
my coordinates i could sum them up
so that's this map here
and then i can send so here's a here's
another example so from r to r to the n
the map that sends
one
to
one one one
one
this is
this map is sn invariant
because
um if i act by sn on this if i permute
the coordinates it stays the same
and so basically there's two ways that i
can go in an sn invariant ways from here
to here i can do the identity map
or i can go from
n to the identity into the
one-dimensional space and then back
again and this is it
so that's the that's the important point
this is it
so
by imposing the symmetry you cut down
this n squared dimensional space
down to a two dimensional space
i hope that was helpful
yes fine uh i think there's another
question on the file
yes so
yeah so what is the general intention
uh
yeah i mean
um
in some sense it's it's difficult for me
because i don't i don't know what you
know and what you don't know
um
my intention is just to present
something that i think is is beautiful
and useful
um
and
yeah i hope that you have some picture
of um of what a convolutional
neural net is and how it can be viewed
through group theory
and i also hope that
um
you're aware of the fact that um like
these kind of equivariance
considerations can help you design
neural nets
i think there is one last question also
on the file
uh-huh
what other properties we are looking for
on the sphere
yeah it depends um
like you might be
you might be trying to predict
for example
you might like take the surface of the
earth and you might be out trying to
predict the weather or you might have a
ball and you're trying to predict the
heat
the heat distribution on this ball in 10
minutes or there's many different
problems that could could occur
obviously
okay so thank you
thank you
have a good morning